There's nothing particularly innocuous about this statement.
X is already in scope. In fact, it's 3, so this is going to assign x to be 4.
I don't think this will prevent us from printing "sindbad".
This one, though, says x is x divided by 0.
Division by 0 doesn't really make sense
and will typically cause the Python interpreter to stop and say,
"You are asking me to do impossible math,"
and thus not execute subsequent statements.
Assigning x the string value "return" doesn't have the same effect
as actually executing a return statement, so this won't help us.
But x = y, well, if this is the entire program,
then there is no y in scope, so Python will yell at us and say,
"Oh, you're referencing an undefined variable."
So just to make these examples clear, let's actually see it in the interpreter.
This time I've left in x = x + 1, which should not prevent us from seeing Sindbad.
And there he is. But if I print out x = x / 0, no, we don't get Sindbad
and instead we get this error message from Python,
"Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah"--the part here at the bottom is the most important--
"ZeroDivisionError: integer division or modulo by zero."
Well, we did ask you to do that, so it's our own fault.
Similarly, x = y we don't see Sindbad and instead we see
"NameError: global name 'y' is not defined."
So both of those 2 errors caused us not to see Sindbad.